it's a weird position isn't it there's
you Dr Jordan Peterson this guy that
comes out of Canada lecturing students
and then you're at the home of the
greatest football player of all time and
you'll genuinely helping him I mean
Ronaldo is known as one of the most
mentally strong athletes has ever been
yeah right not just physically but
mentally strong and yet he needed
someone like you to help him I find that
really fascinating well I don't know if
he needed me because he's a pretty
competent guy but but you know you can
always and this is something that very
competent people do you can always
improve on edge you know and so his life
is very well put together and he had
some trouble but people do but we talked
a lot about what he wanted how he wanted
his career to end in in the most
graceful possible Manner and how that
might be optimized and so I hope you
told him very well to sign for Arsenal
in the January transfer window did you
Jordan no I didn't give it to Mike I
don't give I try not to give people
advice